a water supply shortage in Austin Texas
is now an emergency according to city
officials they've ordered more than a
million customers to boil their tap
water before drinking it recent heavy
flooding has contaminated the city's
reservoirs with mud and debris david beg
no is in austin with the efforts to fix
the problem
david good morning hey Nora good morning
we're reminded a story like this how
much water influences just about
everything we do here at monkey nest
coffee they're open 24 hours a day like
most businesses now they've got the sign
on the door telling people about the
water shortage and inside coffee's about
70 percent of their business but the
only thing they're serving this morning
is iced coffee that was pre prepared the
expresso machine is covered up in the
coffee brewer is shut down
listen city wide right now there is a
run on bottled water you are
hard-pressed to find it local leaders
say Austin could run out of water if
residents don't take immediate action
it's imperative that not only you boil
water that you're gonna consume but you
do all that you can to reduce the amount
of water that you use until we can get
through this event the city's warning
sent people rushing to stock up on
bottled water
stripping store shelves clean healthy
ficials say that tap water may contain
bacteria and viruses that could make
people sick these organisms are
extremely small and even potentially a
droplet of water that is affected
couldn't be enough to cause an illness
recent historic flooding has washed mud
silt and other contaminants into the
Colorado River and nearby lakes that
supply Austin's water in response the
city shut down portions of its three
treatment plants for cleaning customers
in Austin typically use about 120
million gallons of water every day
normally we could produce over 300
million gallons a day
we haven't been much over a hundred for
the last two days among the hardest hit
are the city's restaurants some owners
have decided to close their doors until
they can safely reopen this is the first
time you know in history that we have a
problem like this so we can't take it
lightly as of this morning none of the
water tests have come back positive for
bacteria now bianna this is important to
point out the water filters that we
usually use in our home they really
don't filter for bacteria and viruses so
it's best to boil it and when you do
experts say boil for at least three
minutes some good tips there David thank
you water restrictions are in effect in
the city as well wait David are you the
only one at the monkey Nescafe where's
all the people are they hiding one only
one kitchens quiet right now
there's like they're sleeping in and
Austin this morning all right David
thank you thank you David now